let's end him
i'm going for the most dryish position
there is
the the level of this is probably
the most drawish opening that there is
in all of chess
but of course you know hans neiman you
know i have my ways
of of messing things
okay f5 okay he's
he's going sir for some very dubious
stuff
okay
interesting
i'm sorry
slow it down ons slow it down
thanks
much
stop move ons
don't move
so
enter it
super double-edged buds
my position is just better here
i don't believe that he's fine here and
there's just simply no
no way
okay just left to convert
if he takes okay now i just need to fit
it
close it out just close it out
it's getting double edged though
probably shouldn't have
let it get to this point to be honest
but what's done is done
okay that's definitely good
okay that's correct
okay no
you can't mess you cannot mess this up
once
no room for air here hans no room for
just just move just move just move just
move
okay so the key variation
is queen d2 e6
and then um
i have some interesting ideas
but the two bishops
queen d2 e6
should be is completely fine
completely fun
okay now i've
calculated the win here
or have i
i've been saying or have i way too many
times
okay
yeah i got him
this is some puzzle [ __ ] right here
this is some [ __ ] puzzler [ __ ] right
here
all that puzzle rush
if takes takes bishop c4 c4 takes e
takes a faith or takes f8
rook e7 suck my balls
uh
how am i this good at this game how am
i this [ __ ] good
holy [ __ ]
i am the [ __ ] best
oh my
oh my [ __ ]
god get [ __ ] down and bow
down how the [ __ ] did i see that
holy [ __ ] how did i calculate that
oh my god i am so [ __ ] good at this
game
number 32 in the world
let's go
that was so [ __ ] close
oh my god
yes
dude dude can we look at this look at
this calculation
in this position after e6
i kid you not i calculate
to the final position
i calculated 11 moves ahead queen
sacrifice that was the most disgusting
[ __ ] i've ever seen in my life
sorry sorry sorry sorry bye-bye
yes thank you that's good
if